irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
nous sommes en italie à lipari très
exactement
c'est à 25 août aura bien peu en avance
ou cela réchauffe et c'est aussi la fête
du village
tout se passe dans la rue la rue
principale du port de lee perry comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer il est assez
pauvre tout le ravitaillement vienne
sicile et à l'occasion de cette fête on
la porte fruits et pastèques vendus en
tranches pour cinq à dire l'on dévore
sur place le marchand de poisson salé
est aussi venu cet honneur ces deux
géants font aussi part qu'il a fait ils
s'en vont du lan nîmes de village en
village
ici on fabrique et créancière mans
union lui fait partout toujours un
attroupement et sitôt la demi-heure
spectacle terminé le propriétaire mais
sont dignes hall sur son dos en vain sur
la pièce voisine pour donner une
nouvelle séance des guignols ou plutôt
puisque nous sommes vandal id pulcinella
le polichinelle italien est un peu
différent du nôtre
il est droit au lieu d'être reçue devant
et derrière
j'étais venu en blanc il ya un ennemi
masse tandis que le nôtre à chaque fois
avec deux cornes
mais tous les deux ont une voix enrouée
louisiane ils sont tapageur querelleur
et là l'histoire est bien vendu leurs
histoires sont les mêmes
on se distrait par tous et comme on peut
ce biais d'un jeu de carte nationale
quels en sont les règles ça cela vous
franchement ne pas pouvoir vous les
donner mais peut-être les connaissiez
vous
sur le port à côté des jeunes qui jouent
les vieux travail un travail fait la
patience car il s'agit de démêler
d'enrouler un cercle de kilomètres de
files ou qu'elles sont fixés les âmes
sombre
ceci vous paraît la pêche de la nuit
parfois malgré le nombre impressionnant
de la leçon il n'y a que deux ou trois
poissons pris au piège le lendemain
matin
et ce n'est guère encourageant
et maintenant passion du plat national
par une seul à regarder ces enfants leur
métier quand transporter les phases
d'espresso à travers la ville sur les
people
je vous laisse imaginer que peut-être la
conversation éloquence tout l'accueil
nous ses mains et autres ballets
la tomate sévit jerry heureusement dans
la vie elle est généralement accommoder
avec des quatre le câprier vous l'a fait
devant les yeux il pousse à l'état
sauvage les cas pour doivent être
ramassés en boutons l'écueil mois de
juillet dès qu'ils sont formés et avant
qu'il ne devienne fleurs on les fait
mariner dans du gros sel pendant un mois
ils sont alors prêts pour la
consommation puis on les trie par taille
les faisant passer à travers des tamis
des diverses grosseur ensuite on les met
en sacs de plastique de 5 ou de 10 kg et
on les placards des caissettes pour les
expédier nous avons affaire ici à une
des plus grandes exploitations de lille
sur place on en consomme énormément
les caps ont toujours à conserver l'eau
du sel jamais dans du vinaigre comme
chez nous et câprier sont une des
ressources de l'île avec les vignes les
figuiers et la pierre ponce
ces groupes barque que vous voyez à
l'ancré dans le port de lipari sont
chargés jusqu'au bord de pierre ponce
elles sont chargées même qu'elles ne
peuvent naviguer que par m très calme
sinon la cargaison arriverez mouillée
qui serait catastrophique
elles sont là depuis huit jours à
attendre le calme plat et pourtant
regardez la mère n'a pas l'air mauvais
des bateaux de tout un âge qui
proviennent de tous les pays du monde
même d'amérique viennent
s'approvisionner au pied de cette
montagne qui est tout entière formé de
pons
la réserve est loin d'être épuisé comme
vous voyez et on peut encore tâchée ces
lois dans 115 d'être à court
cette montagne est un ancien volcan son
cratère est un produit non seulement de
la pierre ponce mais aussi de
l'obsidienne l'obsidienne c'est cette
pierre noire venez de blanc brillante
tranchante comme du verre dont les
mexicains par exemple faisait des
couteaux pour les sacrifices
ce gisement est le seul d'europe avec
celui d'islande
aussi étonnant que cela paraisse la
poncer l'obsidienne sont deux résultats
de manifestations éruptive à des
températures différentes dans ces
bâtiments ont lieu différentes
opérations de séchage de la ponce est là
pour y stocker en sa en attendant d'être
acheminés dans les diverses parties
les pierres extraites de la montagne
descendent le long du togo et passe par
des cribles le tri plus ou moins 20 des
cribles effectuer le triage des pierres
selon leur calibre
à l'autre bout de vos gants il y à des
femmes qui les sélectionne et dans tout
le chantier c'est d'ailleurs le seul
endroit où elles sont employées car tout
le reste du travail est beaucoup trop
dur pour elle
la brochure des pierres varie de la
taille d'un oeuf à celle d'une bête
bob's environs de toutes les qualités
diverses que produit la montagne ce sont
ces pierres qui ont le moins le prix
on en fait de l'âge briggs amalgames et
qui servent à construire des hangars des
maisons des maisons bon marché bien
entendu la pompe offre beaucoup
d'avantagés
elle est très résistante au feu elles ne
font qu'à plus de 200 degrés inaltérable
elle isole viennent la chaleur du froid
et du son dans le pays mais on n'en pas
les rues la poussière recouvre tout
pénètre partout et volent partout et je
voyais doivent grimper en sont contents
jusqu'à nimeley de cette pauvre brûlant
penser qu'il fait l'impact 40
ils travaillent huit à dix heures par
jour gagné 12 cents ligne ont taillé la
montagne par tranche avec des pics
ce qui est dangereux à cause des
mouvements il se laisse glisser ensuite
le long de la pente en entraînant la
poudre mais qu'elle travaille ensuite
pour remonter céda travail exténuant
il faut vraiment une santé de fer pour
mon instinct c'est aussi un travail
dangereux surtout l'été car en respirant
cette poule aux seiches les ouvriers
attrape la silicose
toute cette matière extraite de la
montagne doit descendre jusqu'à la mer
peu importe par quels moyens wagon
camion vespa ruban mécanique et lois de
la pesanteur
il y à différentes qualités de poule aux
fines elles varient de la grosseur d'un
grain de riz à une poussière vraiment
impalpable que la protéine plus elle est
précieuse
on l'envoie dans le travail des métaux
de l'ivoire dumars dans l'industrie des
savons au lait produit détersif pour la
rendre encore plus fine et la
débarrasser le tout à fureter on l'a
fait passer dans des fours où les
ouvriers qui font ce travail qui sont à
l'intérieur portent des masques
ça c'est le travail ou plus dangereux
tous ils donnent droit quand lieu
plupart vous il y en a d'autres qui
dehors est à la poudre la ratissant pour
la paire sécher au soleil
ceux là n'ont pas de protection malgré
les nuages de poussière qui soulève et
imaginer ce que je peux être les jours
de sirocco chaque jour où il étale une
nouvelle couche de poudre pour la faire
sécher un seul jour suffit car le soleil
est brûlant du haut en bas de la
montagne tout est devenu blanc les
hommes les arbustes les bâtiments les
rochers quelquefois seulement l'hiver
avec les grosses pluies nature reprend
son aspect normal assez rare le ruban
mécanique que venait de voir date de
l'an dernier il amène la marchandise
directement sur le bateau et permet de
charger 300 tonnes à l'heure des bateaux
de tous genres viennent charger la
pierre fons
certains prennent la poudre en vrac
d'autres la poudre plus fine en sac
ce vieux trois mares trapu comme un
cargo du siècle dernier bien terminé les
blancs prend direction en italie et nous
apercevrons juste au moment de terminer
nous aussi les îles de ban area de
stromboli
hélène chaillot vous a proposé voyage
son passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec des films de maxime
clairet montage rené garrisson roger
fait jean-paul qui emploie script
marcelo chez illustration sonore dominic
palladini réalisation sur leurs
spectateurs